>> IF YOU THOUGHT THE SUMMER
PLAYING SEASON WAS BAD BUCKLE UP
YOUR LABOR DAY WEEKEND
13 MILLION OF YOU TO APPLY FROM
THE U.S. AIRPORT.
THAT IS A BIG JUMP FROM LAST
YEAR AND BOY, IS IT GOING TO BE
A PAIN IN THE YOU KNOW WHAT.
3,000 FLIGHTS DELAYED AND 300
CANCELED.
SO WHAT IS MAYOR PETE GOING TO
DO ABOUT THE TRAVEL CHAOS?
NOT MUCH APPARENTLY.
HE LAUNCHED A WEBSITE TO SEE HOW
AIRLINES TREAT YOU WHEN THEY
CANCELED THEIR FLIGHT.
BUDDY AS AIRLINES TO PROVIDE
FOOD, VOUCHERS BUT NOTHING TO
FIX THE ACTUAL PROBLEM.
DELAYED AND CANCELED FLIGHTS.
JUDGE, WHY DO YOU THINK ALL
THESE FLIGHTS ARE BEING DELAYED
AND CANCELED?
>> Judge Jeanine: FIRST OF
ALL, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE FLYING
NOW.
A LOT OF PILOTS ARE NOT FLYING
HERE IN AND I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW HOW HAPPY I AM WITH
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
BECAUSE PETE BUTTIGIEG AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION IS
MAKING SURE THAT THE RULES ARE
FOLLOWED.
HE IS EXPANDING THE RIGHTS OF
PASSENGERS.
AND IF THEY DELAY YOU, YOU GET A
MEAL OR $10, WHICH WILL BUY YOU
A DRINK ONLY AND NOT A MEAL.
THEN HE SAYS HE'S CAN'T RATING
OPTIONS TO WRITE THE RULES.
THIS IS ALL I'VE GOT TO SAY TO
YOU.
YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION WEBSITE IF
YOUR FLIGHT IS DELAYED OR
WAITING ON THE TARMAC.
YOU SHOULD GET $300 OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, I FORGET WHAT IT
IS, AND YOU CHECK ON THE
DASHBOARD EACH AIRLINE.
BECAUSE THE AIRLINES OWE YOU
MONEY.
DON'T JUST SAY, YOU KNOW, G, MY
AIRLINE GOT CANCELED.
THEY MAY OWE YOU MONEY.
THEY WILL CANCEL KNOWING THEY
WILL PACK THE NEXT FLIGHT.
>> Joey: IT IS NOT FUN.
I FLY DELTA WAY TOO MUCH BECAUSE
I LIKE TO BE HOME MORE BUT I
WORK IN NEW YORK AND GEORGIA.
THAT IS THE PRICE I PAY AND I
DON'T MIND IT.
I LIKE FLYING ON DELTA.
>> Greg: YOU WANT TO GET
SOMETHING FROM DELTA.
>> Judge Jeanine: WE LOVE
DELTA.
>> Joey: I'M TRYING TO BE
JUDICIOUS HERE.
JESSICA, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
MAYOR PETE, THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT BUT THE
WAY THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
ARE IT WAS HARD FOR ME TO
UNDERSTAND.
BUT I GUESS KIND OF PILOT THEY
SHOULD OFFER YOU A CASH VOUCHER
BACK.
BUT THEY ARE ONLY OFFERING
FLIGHTS.
WHAT CAN MAYOR PETE DO OR WHAT
SHOULD YOU DO OR WHAT CAN HE DO?
>> Jessica: IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE HAS TO BE TWO PARTS, ONE
ABOUT SOMETHING WITH THE
AIRLINES AND THEY HAVE TONS OF
BAILOUT MONEY ALSO.
SO WHAT YOU ARE ASKING ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN SCHOOLS AND
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
AIRLINES, YOU KNOW, MILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, SPEND IT
PROPERLY AND MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND THE PILOT TRAINING
PROGRAM TAKES LONGER AND IT'S
NOT LIKE HIRING SOMEONE OFF OF
THE STREET.
BUT AS YOU WERE EXPLAINING IN
THE GREEN ROOM, THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PREPARED FOR THIS BECAUSE
THIS WAS SOMETHING BREWING FOR A
FEW YEARS.
OBVIOUSLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC, HAD A HIGHER OCTANE
THERE.
SO YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
ARE TAKING CARE OF AND GIVEN THE
VOUCHERS AND MEALS.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM
PEOPLE GET STRANDED IN A CITY
THEY DON'T LIVE, THEY HAVE TO GO
RENT A HOTEL ROOM FOR THE
NIGHT, WHICH YOU KNOW IS NOT
CHEAP.
SO, THEY NEED TO MEET BOTH SIDES
OF THAT.
>> Joey: DIDN'T FULLY ANSWER
MY PROBLEM.
BUT KAYLEIGH I WANT TO ASK YOU.
WE TALK ABOUT WHY THIS IS
HAPPENING AND I AM NICE TO MY
NEIGHBORS.
THIS PROBLEM HAS BEEN BREWING
FOR A WHILE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED
IS AIRLINES TOOK PPP MONEY UNDER
THE AUSPICE OF NOT LAYING INTO
ALL OF YOU ALL BUT INCENTIVIZED
TO RETIRED SO THEY COULD GET OFF
THE PAYROLL BUT THE MONEY THE
DID NOT HAVE TO PAY BACK.
SHOULD THE AIRLINES HAVE TO PAY
SOME OF THE PPP MONEY BACK?
>> Kayleigh: YEAH, THAT IS A
GREAT POINT.
THEY TRY TO HAVE THEIR CAKE AND
EAT IT TOO.
THAT CAKE HAPPENED TO BE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
HERE WE ARE $54 BILLION LATER,
BUT DON'T WORRY.
TO THE JUDGE'S POINT, BIG BAD
PETE BUTTIGIEG IS ON THE CASE.
BIG BAD PETE BUTTIGIEG MADE A
DASHBOARD FOR US THIS WEEKEND.
A DASHBOARD YOU THINK
INTERACTIVE WEBSITE, LET'S GO ON
THE PEOPLE TO BUDGE DASHBOARD
APPEARED NORMALLY, YOU CANNOT
PRINT A DASHBOARD BUT A CHART OF
A POSTER BOARD YOU WOULD CREATE
THAT HAS ALL THE AIRLINES LIST
OF THE CHECKS AND EXITS.
AS TO WHETHER THEY OFFER
REFUNDS, OFFER MEALS.
THIS HAS DONE A DASHBOARD BUT
FIVE PEOPLE IN A PIZZA OFFICE
WHO PUT TOGETHER SOMETHING SO WE
CAN HAVE A LONG WEEKEND.
I HOPE YOU ARE ENJOYING YOUR
TIME, PETE, WE ARE LOOKING AT
YOUR -- BOARD AND GETTING NO
ANSWERS.
>> Joey: GREG, THE PROBLEM
GOES DOWN TO THE SUPPLY CHAIN WE
HAVE PEOPLE AT THE L.A. AIRPORT
TO TAKE THE BAGS OFF AND SIT
THERE AND WAIT THREE HOURS?
THERE WERE PEOPLE THAT OWN
BUSINESSES THAT SUPPLY PARTS TO
THE AIRPLANES AND SOME
MECHANICAL IF YOU PUT ON THE
GROUND FOR SIX MONTHS, IT WILL
BREAK SITTING THERE INSTEAD OF
FLYING.
YOU HAVE A BACKLOG ON THIS.
SO CHANGE IS A BIG PART OF IT.
THE GOVERNMENT IS MAKING SURE TO
BUY A HOTEL ROOM AND GIVE YOU A
MEAL.
I THINK THERE IS MORE TO DO.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
LOOK, I HAVE TO DEFEND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HERE BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE WE CAN FIND A SEGMENT
ON THIS TOPIC FROM TWO YEARS
AGO, FIVE YEARS AGO, EIGHT YEARS
AGO AND IT WOULD SOUND THE EXACT
SAME.
WHENEVER YOU DO TRAVEL SEGMENTS
IN HIGH PEAK PERIODS, IT IS ALL
ABOUT CANCELLATIONS.
AT THE SOLE ABOUT COMPLAINTS WHY
NOTHING EVER CHANGES.
IT IS NOT REALLY THE LACK OF
PREPARATION.
IT IS A LACK OF AIRLINE
INDUSTRY.
AND IMAGINE THE COMPUTER CHIP
INDUSTRY PROGRESSED LIKE THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY.
THIS PHONE WOULD WEIGH 4 TONS TO
DO THE EXACT SAME THINGS THAT I
WANT IT TO.
OUR COMPUTERS WOULD BE WALLS AND
WALLS OF WIRES.
THAT IS BECAUSE SOMEHOW THE
COMPUTER INDUSTRY IS CONSTANTLY
INNOVATING.
ALWAYS TRIPLING ITS COMPUTER
POWER WHAT EVERY THREE YEARS OR
SOME CRAZY THING.
WE NEED TO START LOOKING AT
AIRLINE TRAVEL WITHIN A NEW
BRAIN.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME NEW
THINKING ABOUT THIS.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT WOULD
YOU DO?
>> Greg: WE KNOW SMALLER
PLANTS CAN GO FASTER AND START
MAKING SMALLER PLANES.
MAYBE WE START HAVING
TAXICABS, DRONES -- LOOK,
RELEASING THE PRESSURE OF THE
LONG HAUL FLIGHTS WITH SHORTER
FLIGHTS THAT MIGHT WORK.
WHAT DO I KNOW?
>> Judge Jeanine: MORE
CONNECTIONS.
THAT IS TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: OR DIRECT FLIGHTS
BETWEEN LITTLE THINGS AND THIN
ELECTRIC BIKES FOR EVERYONE.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE YOU GO.
>> Joey: WELL, I THINK THREE
WILLS ARE BIKES.
IF YOU ARE SITTING AT HOME READ
THE FINE PRI